Good morning, John.
[Hank makes goat noise]
You know how I said that I lost the charger to my camcorder...
Well, I did, and I don't have any way to record this video.
So, I'm lucky enough to have a lot of footage that I took
over at mom and dad's house, some of it, quite graphic.
I mean, it's not like 'two girls and one cup' or anything.
Like look, these are baby chicks and these are just pigs...
and these are two girl pigs mounting each other. I have nothing wrong with that.
But coming up is something that's a little bit disturbing.
It is a goat giving birth to a baby goat.
And while it's not 'two girls and one cup' material,
I would not mind if you people pause the video right now,
and then film yourself watching this,
because I wanna see your reactions because I couldn't see my own
and frankly I would like to have been able to see my own reaction to this.
[shuddering voice]
Oh, goat birth.
In my opinion, what you're about to hear sounds like a velociraptor puking.
And what you're about to see looks like a goat giving birth to a baby goat.
So pause now and record if you would like to show me your reaction.
Otherwise, either stop the video right now.
Get ready for some serious freaky goat birthing.
[song begins]
♪ It was a goat giving birth to a baby goat ♪
♪ It was a goat giving birth, oh god, that's really, really gross ♪
♪ The miracle of life ♪
♪ Right before my eyes ♪
♪ And all I want to do is turn the camera off and hide ♪
♪ It was a goat giving birth to a baby goat ♪
♪ Oh god... (Oh god...) ♪
♪ That's gross! ♪
[song begins]
And, of course, no goat birthing video would be complete without a techno remix.
Hit it, Michael Aranda!
[song begins]
♪ It was a goat giving birth to a baby goat ♪
♪ It was a goat giving birth, oh god, that's really, really gross ♪
♪ The miracle of life ♪
♪ Right before my eyes ♪
♪ And all I want to do is turn the camera off and hide ♪
♪ It was a goat giving birth to a baby goat ♪
♪ Oh god... (Oh god...) ♪
♪ That's gross! ♪
Thank you ever so much to Michael Aranda for doing that amazing arrangement.
And thank you as well to the Katherine for harmonizing with me
because I can never figure out how to harmonize with myself.
And finally, and most importantly, thank you to Christie the goat
for giving birth to not one, not two, not three, but four beautiful baby goats on that day.
My life will never be the same.
John, DFTBA. (Don't forget to Basketball Association.)